Lauren you've been on the show a few
times yes and you usually talk about
your relationships and you talk a lot
and you're very frank yeah about how
they're not going well absolutely yeah
and you describe these absolute
disasters so now you're here and I
almost feel like I have this like
paternal interest in are you please tell
me you're in a good relationship I'm in
a great relationship it's been six
months
his name is Brian he's amazing what I
have to say though is that being on the
show was such an amazing experience both
times but it's really made dating
interesting because when you google my
name the first thing that comes up is
the videos of me on the show yeah so
amazing this show which is amazing but
also every date I've been on since my
last appearance the opening line from
the guy is so I watched your clips on
Conan hangs in the air and what I want
to respond is like oh the one where I
talk about almost dating a homeless man
or the one where I talk about getting
taken from behind in a Denny's bathroom
you know what I mean like which is worse
all that good one yeah I remember those
appearances very well and you were you
have I mean you talk about anything
you're extremely honest but I would
think that yeah if that's out there yeah
in a very public way which it is that
might make it a little strange for you
it's been rough it's been hard I'm not
gonna lie I only went but since that
last time I've only been on three dates
I just realized two of them I dated and
then the one was a was a one-off but but
the last one was Brian so there you go
now had Brian watch the clips well this
is what's interesting he had the same
thing he's like I saw your clips on
Conan and I'm like stealing myself and
then he's like but I realized that
that's a story she probably wants to
tell me and I'm hearing it out of
context so I stopped watching it cuz I
thought I'd like to hear it from you
specifically
[Applause]
but you were to Denny's and it was his
to get okay this he's I'm assuming then
first boys like a gentleman yeah he
sounds like a gentleman about the
internet which soda people are not a
gentleman
who's a gentleman about the internet
like I must stop watching now I withdraw
yeah
withhold my judgment endless
opportunities in front of me to see
anything I've ever dreamed of having sex
with anything else yeah
you